citizens of the reject Nation it's time
for a very special koi's comic Corner
because Spider-Man is my favorite Comic
character so I'm Overjoyed to be ranking
his movies now please do leave a like
subscribe leave in the comments your
ranking and yes we are going to include
across the spider-verse now there will
be no spoilers for across the spider
verse I promise not a one the rest
obviously spoilers those movies been out
for a while but no spoilers for across
the spider-verse as we rank all 10 of
the Spider-Man films number 10.
Spider-Man 3. you knew this was gonna be
this I mean there's not really another
answer I do think Spider-Man 3 is a bit
better than some people might give it
credit for it Is Not Great by any means
but the Sandman stuff really really
works a lot of the darkness of what
Spider-Man's going through works but
there is enough negative there is enough
that doesn't work it has to be the
bottom of the barrel I didn't love the
Ultimate Spider-Man casting of Topher
Grace I didn't love the dancing I didn't
love some of the choices that were made
especially at the cost of not just
Spider-Man but all the characters in
this film when Peter Parker is making
out with Gwen Stacy in front of spider
man before he even gets the Symbiote
it's hard to see him fall from grace
because it feels like he's already
fallen from Grace Sandman however holds
the test of time and I do feel like no
way home redeemed a lot of what the Sam
Raimi movie was supposed to be and I
would love honestly for Sam Raymond to
get the chance to make the Spider-Man 4
he wanted because I wanted to see the
Spider-Man 3 with Sandman without venom
pushed in there a lot works but more
doesn't number nine The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 this is also kind of just
where it needs to live this movie is
Studio interference the movie now this
movie came out pretty deep into the MCU
already being established and I feel
like they were trying to figure out what
to do with Andrew Garfield as Spider-Man
there was talk of an Amazing Spider-Man
3 there was talk of bringing Andrew
Garfield as Spider-Man into the MCU I
feel like there was just so many
what-ifs that it cost the movie a lot of
its own Integrity I don't blame Mark
Webb I don't even blame some of the
writing choices I blame the overall
conversation between the studio and the
writers and the director and the leads
now that said all of those the negatives
the positives are ample the relationship
between Gwen Stacy and Peter Parker is
maybe my favorite Spider-Man
relationship it absolutely sings the
moment with the Green Goblin and the 121
on the clock she literally Falls and the
clock says 121 and that's the issue she
died in that is a genius Easter egg for
Comic fans there's also a lot of
beautiful lore explored here the use of
the z-axis not quite as good as the
first Amazing Spider-Man but really does
work here the fighting with Electro is
visually stunning and this is maybe the
best web swinging in any Spider-Man live
action film you heard me I think this is
the best live-action web swinging and he
moves like Todd mcfarley and he has all
the sensibilities of a spider and I
still think Andrew Garfield is our best
live-action Spider-Man So Amazing
Spider-Man 2 is number nine but I do
have a place in my heart for it that's
higher than a lot of people I think
number eight Spider-Man far from home
Spider-Man far from home is I think a
lot like Amazing Spider-Man 2 a movie
that has a lot going on that doesn't
quite know where to land those things it
is not just a Spider-Man movie it's a
Spider-Man movie in the MCU that uses
some of the characters that has some
ramifications but doesn't quite know
where to put them I think that all the
Spider-Man films in the MCU use the
Spider-Man villains very well not all of
the films but the MCU films really know
how to get these characters to sing I
think using the Tony Stark backstory
with Mysterio was genius I think
Mysterio is a prophetic villain I think
we're getting closer and closer to not
knowing what our reality is I think
using a character from the 60s that
doesn't quite always work on the page
and making him even better on the screen
absolutely elevates far from home that
being said I don't feel like Spider-Man
should always be out of New York he's a
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man why
can't he be in New York I didn't want to
see him go to Europe I wanted to see him
in New York that story would have worked
so much better if it ended with the
Statue of Liberty I know we got there in
no way home but I really wanted some
iconic Spider-Man lore to be explored in
the streets of New York and I feel like
we still haven't gotten there with our
Spider-Man now by the time we get to no
way home we start exploring where that
could go but I do feel like it was a
poor decision to take Spider-Man that we
just got out of New York I feel like
homecoming set him up for one thing and
then he got put in The Avengers movies I
feel like he came back from the Avengers
movies they took him to Europe
Spider-Man still hasn't gotten to be our
guy yet and far from home I think was
the biggest example of that not working
as much as it should have number seven
spider man the first Spider-Man and this
is where I'm gonna start getting some
heat samuramy's Spider-Man is so
important it is very foundational that
does not mean it's better than the next
six films and I know there is a
Nostalgia for some things and I know
sometimes that's deserved and I'm not
saying it's a bad film but I'm not
thinking it's better than the next six
this movie really really really started
a lot of things after blade and it
really allowed for the universe we live
in now to work but there is a lot of
things that don't work for me I think
that Sam Raimi absolutely loves the
Silver age Spider-Man but when you're
mixing the Silver age Spider-Man with
the ultimate era of Spider-Man with the
2000 stuff it does kind of feel
disjointed I think Toby Maguire his
inherent anger as Peter Parker works for
a lot of writer's take on Peter Parker I
don't see Spider-Man as this boiling
rage character unless he has the
symbiote suit on I know it's very
popular to love your characters in black
suits and make them angry and make them
come back from the dead looking at you
certain other character that's very
popular in comics but it doesn't mean
that's the character and I really think
that the first Spider-Man started a
science trajectory of this angry nerd
that was mad at being a nerd as opposed
to someone that wanted to help everyone
as opposed to someone that wanted to
find the right way I also think Green
Goblin was poorly directed as the
character I think that we saw later what
Willem Dafoe could do as the character I
think it was a product of its time which
costs it some and I have to look at this
movie as 2023 looking at Spider-Man not
what 2001 gave us to Spider-Man in 01
create a superhero movie It's amazing we
got the Green Goblin at all but now I
have to put the next six above it as
much as I love Spider-Man as much as I
needed that movie to be as good as it
was and much that movie shaped me at the
exact right age I just can't put it
higher than number seven number six The
Amazing Spider-Man yes I put the Amazing
Spider-Man over the first Spider-Man
because I think this movie understands
who Spider-Man is the biggest complaint
I've heard about the actual portrayal of
Spider-Man is that he's cool Andrew
Garfield is a cool guy but he's not
playing cool that's just who he is Peter
Parker Mary Jane Gwen Stacy and black
cat would like a word with you if you
don't think Peter Parker's cool being
smart and being cool aren't mutually
exclusive things he dresses in a sweater
vest in the 60s because people dressed
in sweater vests and he wore glasses
because he needed glasses he was a nerd
to Flash Thompson and to Betty Brant and
some of the cool kids but he didn't stay
a nerd that wasn't what he was as a
character he has nerdy qualities but I
hate that everyone sees him
skateboarding as like well he's not
Spider-Man there's so much in this first
movie especially with the lizard that
really ties into the science elements I
love how much of a scientist he is and
most of all and this is a very for me
black and white issue I love Gwen Stacy
and Spider-Man's relationship I
mentioned Mary Jane Gwen and black cat
this is a very romantic character I do
not love how much we remove the Romantic
elements from these characters in the
MCU and Amazing Spider-Man didn't remove
it at all it was a fixture it was a
point of pride in this movie Mark Webb
made 500 Days of Summer that's why you
put him on Amazing Spider-Man the
relationship between Emma Stone and
Andrew Garfield was so good it
translated into real life this movie
loves love and it loves their
relationship and Spider-Man's a tragic
figure he's a Shakespearean character
that's always about loss and overcoming
loss and striving through adversity if
you don't love his life you don't love
his adversity if he doesn't have the
When Stacy relationship worked when she
dies it doesn't matter I never really
really believed in Mary Jane and Peter
Parker in the same universe I just
didn't I didn't think they worked I
didn't think they had chemistry I know
they dated in the movies it didn't
translate it translated The Amazing
Spider-Man his web swinging is
immaculate that scene of him and the
sewers doing all the Todd McFarland
poses like he does in the second film
all of that to me is Spider-Man it had
Studio problems it had writing problems
there are problems but to me The Amazing
Spider-Man is more Spider-Man than the
first Spider-Man number five Spider-Man
two this is with good reason one of the
most beloved superhero comic book films
of all time and it's number five that's
how good the Spider-Man films are
putting this list together was insane
because on any other top 10 list you'd
be hard-pressed to find where to put the
Spider-Man movies because they're near
the top Spider-Man 2 is one of those oh
my God that's when we fixed comic book
movies for a reason the Alfred Molina
stuff absolutely Works The Daily Bugle
is amazing all of the stuff in New York
I love Sam raimi's New York all of those
elements are absolutely Spider-Man
there's so many iconic moments I
remember to this day like him with the
pizza him with the train him with the
Aunt May elements there are things that
I love about this movie but what keeps
it from being in the top four is a lot
of the token wire stuff that I just
don't see as Spider-Man for my personal
interpretation of the character mixed
with scenes like the train scene which
starts out amazing the dock fight on top
all that's great but then the very
heavy-handed like maskless Spider-Man
not a single New Yorker is gonna sell
him out yes I love that he represents
New York yes I love that Sam Raimi
understands that Spider-Man represents
New York but the suspension of disbelief
between the first and the second is a
giant leap that no one ever finds out
Toby McGuire slash Peter Parker
Spider-Man and there's a lot of those
decisions made in the second film
there's a lot of the things that make
Sam Raimi movies work like the horror
sequence with Doc off that don't quite
fit the film for me I love that sequence
and I love it in the movie but when I
look at Spider-Man I don't think of
those elements I'd love to see a Sam
Raimi directed Crave in the last hunt
I'd love to see some horror stories of
Spider-Man but Doc Ock never felt like
the horror character to play with I
didn't attach to the science as much as
I attached the horror and there were so
many elements like Daniel Day Kim being
his assistant which is crazy to look at
there's so many science elements that
could have been dove into more it's
number five five it's high up it'd be in
the top 10 of damn near any list but the
top four even higher for me number four
Spider-Man homecoming and this is maybe
my most controversial take on the
Spider-Man lore and that as much as
Alpha Molina is beloved for good reason
he's an incredible villain in the
Spider-Man movies but for me I think the
vulture did all of the things that
people love about Molina's take but a
little bit better for me like for
example in the comics the big twist on
Norman Osborne is that he's Harry
Osborne's Dad it's someone you didn't
expect all these things and then they
did that in the movies with another
flying green character and made it the
love interest father they tied in all
the John Hughes elements of him being a
kid and having that inherent fear and
respect for a paternal figure nothing
scarier than meeting your prom date's
dad and then it's the vulture tying that
youthful energy into a Twist from the
comic books but subverting expectations
so we're surprised and that whole scene
in the car where Michael Keaton deftly
overpowers Spider-Man verbally and the
lighting shows you who they are it
reminds me of the first Spider-Man when
at Thanksgiving Green Goblins wearing
Spider-Man colors and Spider-Man's Green
Goblin colors but with lighting and then
you've got the vulture himself who's
literally Scavenging the remnants of the
MCU that's the perfect way to bring in a
Spider-Man villain you tie it into Tony
Stark in a really fun way which they
didn't get in very well with Mysterio I
love the lore built in the mythology and
the texture and the quilt that is the
MCU weaving into Spider-Man like a web
and I think that honestly Tom Holland is
Spider-Man even though I don't love that
he has the tech suit even though I don't
love that he's always like the right
amount of power and we don't get him to
be the friendly neighborhood Spider-Man
this is the movie we got the closest I
love him getting the bike and the churro
I love him figuring out his town I love
him figuring out all the elements of
like going to the bodega and then like
you know making sure it doesn't get
destroyed in the next there's so much
right about Spider-Man homecoming I feel
like it gets overshadowed because Iron
Man's in it but Iron Man isn't as
distracting as people remember that's
just what the posters were if you watch
it he's not in it as much as I think
people remember and it does tie
beautifully into this now I do think
there's Spider-Man in the comics which I
consider Andrew Garfield there's
Spider-Man in the Silver age which I
consider Toby McGuire the best possible
way to bring Spider-Man into the MCU was
Spider-Man homecoming and that's not to
mention the fact we got not one but two
Shockers we got Donald Glover tying in
his whole Donald for Spider-Man campaign
and being basically the proto-prowler
and being one of the best tie-ins of all
time and him getting webbed to a car
that has a license plate with his
character's first appearance there's so
much love for Spider-man and homecoming
that it is easily top four for me it was
actually hard to put it here number
three into the spider-verse again I said
after five it's gonna be just hot takes
into the spider-verse is a five-star
film which means the next two are also
five star films for context I've given
22 films five stars three of them are
Spider-Man that's insane this character
has so much that we identify with and
that's what this first movie is about
into the spider-verse is anyone can wear
the mask I'm gonna be totally honest I
was worried because the spider-verse
comic storyline felt like okay how can
we make more Spiderman and to sell toys
and this did the opposite of
commodification this made it like oh
wait these Spider-Man have all of these
plot points and narratives that really
really work getting rid of Moreland and
telling the story that they needed to
sell for the movie was bold because of
that that was the comic storyline
instead they were able to in an animated
movie that's under two hours explain
quantum theory for adults and children
while telling the most compelling
Spider-Man story to that point and it's
able to introduce so many characters you
love immediately it brings you spider
Gwen who much like in my opinion miles
elevated beyond the comic material I
love miles in the comics I love spider
Gwen in the comics I never was like
these guys are better than Peter Parker
I just didn't connect to them as much
because I'd been with Spider-Man Peter
Parker my whole life this movie showed
me they're all Spider-Man and this movie
showed me how they're different and it's
not just their powers it's who they are
as people and it gives me all of that in
less than two hours while being one of
the most visually stimulating and
stunning movies I've ever seen while
holding up to this day is one of the
most re-watchable movies I've ever
consumed while being a source of joy and
inspiration for anyone that watches it
and giving us Nick Cage as Spider-Man
Noir there is so much right about into
the spider-verse that I don't know that
it could be number three on any other
comic book movie list if I ever rank the
top 200 comic book movies it might be
three there too this is crazy love this
number two no way home and here is where
everyone's gonna be like ah recency bias
and that movie's not that good and
without the tie-ins with those
characters it's nothing that's not true
the movie does tell the finale of a six
movie origin which is so ambitious and
so bold it is a story of power and
responsibility that puts our Spider-Mans
that we've loved our Spider-Man that
we've loved for our entire child in
adulthoods as the Uncle Ben figures it
makes Aunt May such a a more important
character in our MCU Spider-Man's life
while making those Spider-Mans the Uncle
Ben's it gives us meme moments that
actually actually work it gives us
dialogue that explains away plot holes
from the past it gives us nostalgia in a
way that is more authentic to plot than
I think any recall ever I love that
Nostalgia is so important because I
think it's really important to remember
the good times but it's also important
to make new good times this movie
uniquely reminds us of the good times
while building more new Good Times Tom
Holland is at his absolute best here the
scenes of him in anguish the scenes of
him fighting the Green Goblin sequence
where he's literally tearing a building
down around him the feast building all
of the things that he's able to do with
his incredible acting and physicality
Elevate Tom Hall and Spider-Man while we
have the supporting characters of Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire also my
problems with Toby Maguire went away in
this movie he even acknowledges his
anger being a negative then Andrew
Garfield acknowledging the way he's had
to cope and deal with things it gave me
an Amazing Spider-Man 3 and a Spider-Man
4 verbally while improving Tom Holland
and I haven't even mentioned the
villains we get beautiful new takes on
Old characters we get the best Green
Goblin I can possibly imagine we get
Redemption for Alfred Molina with the
way his character landed I love Alfred
Molina's dock I love him even more here
I actually felt the adversity with the
tentacles I actually felt Sandman not
knowing how to handle this situation I
actually felt all of these characters
trying to figure out why a Sinister Six
would exist which is exactly the kind of
characters they are in the comic books
but even better to have it translate
through actors giving us so much behind
their eyes this movie is a perfect three
Spider-Man movie it is a perfect almost
Sinister Six movie it is a perfect MCU
installment and it's doing all of that
at once with Incredible visuals and
incredible love for a character that
I've loved since I could read I learned
to read with this character and
Spider-Man no way home made me feel like
I was reading what my childhood promised
me could be made into a movie while as
an adult and I could not possibly
Express how much that movie means to be
number one I cannot honestly believe I'm
saying this because says what I just
went through trying to encapsulate how
much I love no way home I didn't think
anything could top it I honestly didn't
think anything could top into the
spider-verse so the fact that no way
home affected me so much I I was
flabbergasted I've only seen it once but
I think this is where it lands across
the spider verse is my favorite
Spider-Man movie across the spider verse
is something I need to do a six hour
dissertation on there's gonna be a
spoiler talk tomorrow on this very
Channel there's a spoiler free video
already up of me reviewing this movie
and a spoiler on my own channel so
there's lots of places to hear me deep
dive because frankly
I need to to do it justice but in brief
this movie does everything that into the
spider-verse did for more characters
this movie does it with characters that
I was more invested in one because I was
more invested in miles and Gwen this go
around because of how good a job the
first movie did it has the opposite of
the sequel problem instead of trying to
go bigger and louder and Bolder it
accomplishes bigger and louder and
Bolder but its goal is to go deeper the
goal of this film is to feel for all
these characters more not sensationalize
these characters it happens to be
perhaps the most impressive bit of
Animation I've ever seen I think it is
the most impressive translation of any
medium to animation of all time I cannot
fathom how this movie exists but all of
that is secondary to the characters all
that is secondary to how much you feel
for these characters and it's not just
the characters we met in the first
Spider-Man 2099 has so so much going on
spot is one of the villains I never
thought we'd see on screen and he is
utilized here master and that is one
thing that I didn't expect from this
movie it has I think and I'm not gonna
be hyperbolic here I've been thinking
about it for a week I think this is my
favorite Cameo appearance in the history
of movies and that's personal to me it's
not gonna be everyone's favorite Cameo
appearance but it's my favorite Cameo
appearance in movies and it does all of
that while doing some things I can't
talk about until this boiler review
because those things are so much and
they're so impactful but it never leaves
behind our two leads and this movie is
effectively a spider Gwen movie as much
as it's a Miles Morales movie this movie
is about how you wear the mask this
movie is about the world of Spider-Man
and what Spider-Man is to me is family
and it's power and responsibility and
it's taking care of your loved ones and
this movie takes the time to take care
of its loved ones and us who love it
we're Spider-Man's family we're as loved
ones we care about this character so
much this movie's a love letter to us
from Lord and Miller this movie makes
sure that we are receiving all of that
and and and I did and uh I I cried so
much and I cheered so much and I
believed in visuals I didn't think could
translate and I I just saw what I've
always wanted a Spider-Man movie to be I
want to thank them so thank you and
everyone that made across spider versus
my number one Spider-Man film of all
time I'm excited to talk about it
tomorrow on the spoiler live chat I'm
excited to talk about it on my own
spoiler view I'm excited to talk about
it in the video that's already up in
this channel the non-spoiler because
that three minutes was hard to keep to
three I wanted to go like 20 but Craig's
sitting right there and he's going koi
how long is this video gonna be like 82
minutes and I was like no blow that
maybe 20 and like 30. but that's beside
the point I love to cross the spider
verse I hope you love across the spider
verse I've only seen it the ones and I
usually wait to rank them until I've
seen it twice but I think that's where
it lives and I'm so excited to see it
again and I'm so proud to be a
Spider-Man fan so uh check out across
the spiderverse it is now playing see it
big see it loud all the all the catchy
things and let me know in the comments
below what you think your ranking is but
in all honesty I would see it in IMAX
and I'm gonna go see it again in 3D
because I saw it in 2D and I'm curious
how it translates let me know in the
comments what you think of across the
spider verse let me know what you think
of my list let me know what your list is
like comment subscribe and koi's comment
Corners back you guys asked for it I was
so excited to see all the comments one
in koi's common corner this was the best
thing to come back to much much love
I'll see you soon with another one
foreign